bonsoir nous sommes le 10 février les 18
heures si vous nous rejoignez rejoignez
en direct sur tv fil 78 lors du journal
de la rédaction et pour débuter une
photo un tweet plus précisément celui de
jamel debbouze vendredi soir pour saluer
la venue de françois hollande attrape le
président assisté à une rencontre
d'improvisation organisé entre deux
collèges de la ville dans le cadre du
trophée culture et diversité
une visite surprise de dernière minute
nous y reviendrons dans un instant avec
la compagnie d'improvisation est déclic
théâtre qui a organisé ce rendez vous
aimez tout d'abord un mot de transport
les saint cyriens l'attendait depuis
longtemps la tangentielle ouest le
projet de tram train qui doit relier
saint cyr au rer a de
saint-germain-en-laye
elle va sans doute devenir une réalité
le préfet a déclaré les travaux et
d'utilité publique les premières
procédures d'acquisitions foncières vont
être lancés dès cette année 4 nuls
attend la tangentielle ouest est un
projet de tram-train qui prolonge la
grande ceinture ouest au nord et au sud
du département
c'est un projet en deux phases et le
préfet vient de déclarer d'utilité
publique
la première phase une phase 1 qui
prolongera saint germain à
saint-cyr-l'ecole cette phase s'étend
sur 18 8 km comprend douze stations et
travers cette commune
le temps de trajet entre ces deux villes
sera ramené de 60 minutes aujourd'hui à
30 minutes
un coût estimé à un peu plus de 220
millions d'euros les travaux de cette
phase 1 pourrait débuter en 2016 pour
une mise en service à l'horizon 2018
la phase 2 elle prolonge la grande
ceinture ouest au nord de saint germain
en laye verra cher et les travaux
pourraient démarrer en 2010 est le
projet de tangentielle ouest pourrait
permettre en 2019 de transporter neuf à
dix millions de voyageurs résistance à
l'agression publicitaire c'est le nom
d'un collectif qui a organisé samedi sa
première action sur saint quentin en
yvelines une action baptisée ville
propre pour obtenir des engagements
fermes de la part des politiques la
publicité trop présentes et trop
intrusive des affiches avec des poèmes
ou des informations ont notamment
recouvertes
les panneaux publicitaires plus
traditionnelles elles encourent la
verrière trappe magny voisins ou encore
mini le bretonneux l'événement du
week-end je vous le disais tout à
l'heure c'est ce déplacement du
président à trappes pour assister à un
match d'improvisation la fondation
culture et diversité organisée à l'école
de musique et de danse
une rencontre entre les collèges gustave
courbet et youri gagarine
françois hollande y a donc assisté dans
le plus grand des secrets sur
l'invitation de jamel debbouze
l'humoriste et comédien vous le savez
qui a fait ses premiers pas sur scène
lors des ateliers 2 déclic théâtre et je
reçois en plâtre aux l'administratrice
codirectrice de déclic théâtre attrape
géraldine pas ça bienvenu merci nous
avoir rejoints pour ce 7,8 l'aktu
comment s'est organisé cette visite
surprise je le disais nous étions
prévenus tout de même on était un petit
peu prévenu quelques jours avant
effectivement on avait l'information
rien n'a filtré rien n'a filtré
on avait des consignes effectivement
vous maintenant les de ce trophée sur sa
tempe
oui on est venu mardi soir mais c'est
vrai que vous aviez caché ça ne pouvait
pas en parler parce qu'effectivement on
avait des consignes donc c'était un
déplacement privé
voilà donc quand on a des consignes de
l'elysée lorient 7e qu'elle quelques
images à l'elysée a réalisé quelques
vidéos vous vous les voyez actuellement
l'antenne on verra aussi quelques photos
que vous avez réalisé avec déclic
théâtre alors pourquoi cette visite
c'était un déplacement privé président
n'est pas venu uniquement pour apprécier
le spectacle j'imagine pour découvrir
l'improvisation théâtrale déjà certaines
c'était une grande découverte et il a
vraiment apprécié il est resté assez
longuement il n'est pas arrivé au tout
début du spectacle puisqu'il arrivait de
de tunisie mais mais pour découvrir des
jeunes match d'impro et puis c'était
aussi une manière de montrer la
considération qu'ils pouvaient apporter
aux jeunes qui pratiquent l'impro et la
considération portée au match d'impro et
à notre travail de compagnie depuis
longtemps sur le territoire ne s'est pas
livré c'était pas prévu dans la passion
n'était pas prévu au match tout à fait
comme il a voté on a de très belles
photos de
vote effectivement il a beaucoup
apprécié il a réussi on a de belles
photos aussi
voilà il était très très intéressés et
donc il a pris part à la fin il a fait
effectivement un discours improvisé
je ne pense pas voilà est alors
justement pour vous ça représente quoi
ce déplacement du président de la
république c'est une reconnaissance du
travail c'est un encouragement pour
l'avenir c'est le début avant des gestes
peut-être plus fort d'engagement à vos
côtés bien sûr c'est une reconnaissance
déjà c'est un geste vers le vert vers
les jeunes auprès desquels on travaille
c'est important quand on leur en
lorraine l'horaire annoncé une heure
avant quand même parce qu'on voulait pas
les mettre trop en difficulté
il était très très extraordinairement
calme al'annonce de l'information par
crises de panique non pas du tout venant
et puis après ce qu'ils disaient c'est
qu'ils avaient vraiment envie de montrer
ce que les jeunes de trappes et est
capable de faire de manière positive de
montrer de vraiment défendez les
couleurs de la ville donc c'est déjà une
reconnaissance pour l'impro pour notre
travail
bien évidemment dans un déplacement du
chef de l'état dans un match avec un
petit enjeu puisque c'était un match
amical dans le cadre du trophée
d'improvisation culture et diversité
forcément on attend on attend une suite
évidemment donc jamais elle a eu une
petite phrase assez assez piquante sur
la fin où effectivement il a dit demain
l'improvisation théâtrale à l'échangé en
france allait changer de visage
sous-entendu monsieur le président vous
êtes là pour voir ce travail il faut
s'engager de manière plus importante
quels sont les engagements peut-être
concrètement que vous aimeriez voir se
mettre en place des engagements plus
importants ça passe parfois par un
soutien financier à vos structures par
l'aide au développement de structures
similaires avec les théâtres dans le
reste de la france
oui alors c'est le principe on est on
est là dans le dans le cadre du trophée
d'improvisation culture et diversité
donc c'est un trophée national
intercollèges on est présent sur cinq
villes
à l'heure actuelle rochefort lille-paris
traque bordeaux bien évidemment
ce trophée est appelé à se développer on
est on vient de recruter quelqu'un qui
va travailler sur le sol depuis 80 ans
oui on est sur la quatrième édition
maintenant il faut qu'ils se développent
plus largement qui soit vraiment
nationale qu'on est celle notre pratique
de l'improvisation théâtrale dans les
collèges relevant principalement de
l'éducation prioritaire parce que c'est
là la préoccupation de la fondation
culture et diversité qui nous qui nous
soutient donc effectivement on attend dé
soutien en matière d'éducation
artistique peut-être du côté de
l'éducation nationale peut être aussi du
côté de la culture puisque dès qu'il
théâtre n'est toujours pas reconnu parmi
les saints de la culture donc
donc voilà 26 juillet pour passer
quelques uns de vos messages on
l'imaginé lors de la ville ont justement
cette reconnaissance par exemple oui
bien sûr et on va continuer à y
travailler pour voilà parce
qu'effectivement le travail de déclic
paye on en voit les effets donc voila et
donc le président était la présence sur
le terrain la visite uniquement pour la
communication vous l'avez pas ressenti
comme ça en tout cas sur le terrain non
on n'a pas ressenti comme ça que comme
ça évidemment ça en fait partie mais
qu'elle était à l'écouté vraiment il est
allé discuter avec avec les jeunes il y
là
le prix des photos avec les jeunes aussi
donc il ya plein de photos qui circulent
sur sur facebook il a discuté avec les
gens il a d'ailleurs été ovationnée
donc voila cela qu il était plutôt bon a
été plutôt surveillance alors que la
cote de popularité du président est en
dessous des 20% sur 37 mais bon il y
avait quelque chose au-delà de l'aspect
politique
il y avait quelque chose de devoir le
chef de l'état à trappes
au milieu de cette patinoire c'est
symbolique c'est fort et ça permet une
prise de conscience du gouvernement par
exemple sur ces questions-là l'impro
aujourd'hui existe au delà de trappes et
pas uniquement à trappes à travers du
coup on a hissé mais c'est vrai que dans
les villes dans lesquelles on est
présent dans le cadre du trophée
on s'est appuyé sur des sur des anciens
de déclic théâtre qui était parti
s'installer en province donc dans un
premier temps en tout cas on a fait
comme ça à bordeaux à lille
à rochefort on a progressivement on va
s'adresser à des aléas des compagnies
qu'on ne connaît pas forcément mais il
va falloir qu'on trouve aussi des
terrains de l'entente parce que tout le
monde ne ne pratique pas l'improvisation
théâtrale comme nous le faisons qui nous
on l'a développée dans une démarche
éducative et particulièrement en milieu
scolaire donc
donc voilà donc ça va se développer
l'accès est difficile on parlait du
milieu scolaire l'accès est difficile à
l'éducation nationale pour déclic
théâtre quelquefois pour montrer montée
des matchs d'impro rentrée dans les
écoles c'est pas toujours facile
alors ma dans le cas du cycliste de
championnat intercollèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale de saint
quentin en yvelines pour ça on est sûr
la 15e édition donc bon on est un petit
peu connue pour faire venir de nouveaux
établissements alors c'est vrai que le
nom de djamel forcément fait dr
forcément intéresse donc
donc en fait on a beaucoup de demandes
donc là maintenant il va falloir on a un
nouveau partenaire cette année qu'est la
caisse des dépôts
donc il faut croiser tout ça et
effectivement il va falloir trouver de
nouveaux financements pour lui de moyen
également pour constituer à détecter les
intermittents du spectacle les comédiens
les metteurs en scène qui travaillent
sur ce projet puisque c'est quand même
beaucoup d'heures d'ateliers chaque
année des matchs donc des cachets pour
les pour les intermittents du spectacle
donc c'est aussi toute cette économie du
spectacle qu'on soutient en développant
ce trophée j'imagine que vous ne serez
peut-être pas réagir mais je vais tout
de même mentionner la réaction du
candidat ump eut dénoncé ya des
élections municipales on ne peut pas
dissocier non plus ce déplacement du
président du contexte et des enjeux il
ya ces élections municipales le candidat
ump udi attrape ottomane nasri et qui a
réagi suite à ce déplacement de françois
hollande par un communiqué il précise
françois hollande est venu simplement
assisté un spectacle d'improvisation le
spectacle a et a montré pour cette
visite de françois hollande qui était
incapable d'improviser ne serait ce que
quelques annonces concrètes pour
répondre aux attentes des habitants
d'une ville qui l'ont pourtant élu avec
77% ils reprochent le manque d'échangés
avec la population sur des questions
comme le chômage le logement la sécurité
j'imagine que vous ne voudrez pas
répondre mais j'ai quand même demandé si
vous avez un sentiment par rapport à ses
déclarations là est ce que ce
déplacement à trappes pour parler d'un
croc dans un cadre festif c'est pas en
décalage avec une réalité qui existe
aussi et des difficultés sur le terrain
de cette population trappistes oui c'est
un moment c'est un moment c'est un
un instant t donc voilà il faut je ne
vais pas réagir là-dessus effectivement
ont été centrées sur l'improvisation
théâtrale sur déclic théâtre
effectivement sur les jeunes dans le
cadre de ce projet évidemment il ya
plein d'autres sujets peut-être plus
important mais là ça n'était pas le
dessus pour hiérarchiser les difficultés
en tout cas là c'était pour parler
d'éducation d'intégration à travers
l'improvisation merci d'être venu nous
parler de cette visite surprise donc de
françois hollande et puis la bonne
continuation à ce trophée culture et
diversité qui commence bien dans cette
année avec ce parrainage ce baptême en
quelque sorte du précédent des comptes
en grande
voilà qui ce qui se poursuit avant la
finale ce sera pas rien c'est le lundi
19 mai au théâtre le comédien paris oui
et on viendra bien sûr suivre tout ça
merci à vous on poursuit ce journal avec
de la politique toujours le dixième
institut d'études politiques lieu paix
va ouvrir prochainement ses portes en
septembre à saint germain en laye un
projet porté par les universités de
cergy pontoise de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines qui a dévoilé son
nom officiel sciences po saint germain
tout simplement sciences po paris
s'étant opposés à la première
proposition de sciences po grand paris
ouest voilà pour l'administratif en tout
cas des portes ouvertes se tenait ce
week end olivier maniscalco et jonathan
vilma l'institut d'etudes politiques
sciences po s'installe dans les yvelines
dès septembre 2014 c'est à saint germain
en laye que la célèbre filière
accueillera une promotion de 80
étudiants une journée portes ouvertes
permettait ce samedi de venir se
renseigner et s'inscrire au concours de
la formation sciences po une formation
que l'institut tente depuis des années
de démocratiser afin de l'ouvrir au plus
grand nombre
on a mis en place un système de
préparation dans des lycées publics 1,2
des territoires plutôt défavorisés qui
là encore est destiné à adil on a aidé
les enfants qui pensent pas forcément à
passer ce type de concours qui n'ont pas
forcément départ les ressources pour le
réussira à le faire la formation
sciences po se déroule en cinq ans avec
deux premières années généraliste et une
troisième année à l'étranger en 4e année
l'étudiant se spécialiser effectué des
stages dans la branche qui l'a
sélectionné la cinquième année
s'effectuera à l'université de
versailles saint quentin ou de
cergy-pontoise deux établissements
partenaires afin d'offrir un choix plus
varié pour les masters 2
désormais sans faire sciences po paris
les étudiants yvelinois ne manqueront
donc de rien le premier atout de cette
super c'est sa situation géographique
puisque il lancé en région parisienne et
que je vivrai viennent donc ça
m'intéresse mais aussi parce qu'il est
associé à des à des universités qui sont
assez reconnus en france
les locaux c'est vraiment ce qui m'a
impressionné en premier parce qu'ils
sont vrais enfin vraiment très beau et
on sait que dans des locaux comme ça
qu'on a vraiment facilement envie de
travailler
les inscriptions au concours sont
ouvertes depuis le 3 février se
clôtureront le 18 avril si les étudiants
boursiers sont exemptés de frais de
scolarité les plus favorisés payeront eu
4000 euros l'année à terme sciences po
saint germain en laye devrait accueillir
près de 700 élèves
le déplacement d'harlem désir ce
dimanche matin à poissy le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste est venu
soutenir et frédérik bernard le maire
sortant qui se retrouvent pour ce
scrutin a notamment posé sur sa ville au
conseiller général karl olive et qui
présente également sur sa liste un autre
ump david douillet député de la 12e
circonscription on passe aux sports en
quelque sorte l'étoile sportive de
trappes qui a vécu un séisme cette
semaine le président mustapha larbaoui
qui a démissionné accompagné de toute
son équipe dirigeante motif à un conflit
sur les équipements la présidence
trappistes réclamée depuis plusieurs
années de nouveaux terrains mustapha
larbaoui avait mis sur pied une
convention avec la commune de la
verrière pour utiliser des terrains
inoccupés donc safa larbaoui qui laisse
derrière lui plus de 900 licenciés une
démission qui soulève tout de même
quelques questions à mon ennemi du
premier tour des élections municipales
sera-t-il candidat voici quelques
éléments de réponse les gens sont en
recherche de
de gens qui sont investis dans la dans
la citoyenneté dans la ville donc bien
sûr j'étais sollicité mais de tous bords
pour les gg dit un jour à monsieur le
maire je pense que lui s'en souviendra
le jour où je serai de la politique sera
le premier à qui j'en parlerai ma parole
est libre à partir de ce soir est pour
l'essentiel du sport mais côté résultats
cette fois-ci rendez vous avec anthony
rech chaque lundi 18h30 le 7-8 sport
également en replay sur notre site
internet je vous retrouve demain pour un
nouveau jt excellente soirée